[Applause]
getting an abortion is not easy making
that decision is not easy it's not
something people do lightly it's not
something that you can just do the
supreme court rules to overturn roe
versus wade abortion laws which marks
the first time in u.s history that the
court has taken away a constitutional
right and celebs are speaking out after
the decision incredibly important former
first lady michelle obama took to
twitter with a lengthy message saying
she's heartbroken especially for future
generations in her letter michelle wrote
this horrifying decision will have
devastating consequences and it must be
a wake-up call especially to the young
people who will bear its burden i'm just
terrified with my girls
viola davis who played michelle obama in
the tv drama the first lady tweeted
she's gutted adding now more than ever
we have to use our voice and power
then there's michelle's husband and
former president barack obama demanding
action as well
barack provided resources to his
followers to join activists protests and
vote in the upcoming november 8 election
to make a change saying the court ruling
is attacking the essential freedoms of
millions of americans
[Music]
another star in shock taylor swift
reposting michelle's letter saying she's
terrified for our country's future the
singer tweeted after so many decades of
people fighting for women's rights to
their own bodies today's decision has
stripped us of that the landmark
decision removes a law that has been in
place for over 50 years which once
banned abortions after 15 weeks of
pregnancy and now it's no more whether
or not dear girl these barbaric laws
will someday be overturned by something
called progress and then after about 50
years after the progress they'll be like
and maybe we should undo the progress
saturday night live addressed the ruling
back in may before it was official
during benedict cumberbatch's guest
appearance and the doctor strange actor
took a stand shedding light on the issue
men who think we should outlaw abortion
forever
say hi
and who's opposed
ney
i'm just playing i know i can't vote but
you know more's gonna be more you know
that same month whoopi goldberg
passionately spoke out on the view her
words ringing true for many after
today's ruling we got tired of tripping
over women in bathrooms public bathrooms
who were giving themselves abortions
because there was nowhere safe nowhere
clean nowhere to go
this law came about because people
wanted people to have somewhere safe and
somewhere clean it has nothing to do
with your religion this is not a
religious issue this is a human issue
elizabeth banks agrees tweeting this is
not the end of this fight for human
rights
padma lakshmi echoes whoopi sentiments
tweeting quote this will only prevent
safe legal abortions from taking place
and sophia bush argues this will never
end abortion only safe abortion quote
this is not about life this is about
control women when they decide
something is not right for them they're
going to take it into their own hands it
seems like josh gad sums up the overall
feeling for many stars tweeting you
don't need 280 characters today just one
word rage
you